yeah finally this is for job don't check
it out so check it out he's got no he's
got it at full size right now but this
is how it comes this is a voyage air
guitar it's foldable like that oh just
like this yeah like this this is an
unbelievable model for somebody who's
just starting to play guitar someone is
our real pro my job
like these are on tour right now with
Paul McCartney Taylor Swift Jimmy
Buffett is it that I actually like to
take this opportunity to announce my own
20 cities actually all right so they go
and these things are like you know
$2,000 guitars that studio professionals
use we've got a deal for you it's
regularly 399 kevin o'leary is the shark
tank investor on it or drop it comes
with this super cool case will get
beside the backpack who would have known
that this guitar suppose instead
backpack think I had also holidays
Christmas I mean graduation really
amazing gifts um and this is your second
job right yeah yeah exactly last week
Sam tried out to be a manicurist you got
the content you've got a whole lot more
on Goodwin ignoring records a commie got
all the details and shark tank don't
miss that don't make sure Appa shark
tank design tomorrow night season finale
at eight o'clock 7 central right here on
ABC